okay I want to start today with a story
that's sort of about Beto O'Rourke but
it's really a story more generally about
campaign finance and about Republicans
and Democrats and political philosophy
and so in the beginning it's going to
seem like I'm sort of picking on betta
or work and a lot of people in the
audience don't like Beto so they want me
to be picking on Beto or work and to
quote Donald Trump there's plenty of
material there if that's what I wanted
to do but I want to sort of set this up
for you based on the facts and then
we'll have a discussion that I think is
an important one
Beto or work running as a Democrat for
president in 2020 he for a while was
making the claim that he did not accept
money from lobbyists and that claim has
been sort of quietly removed it's just
disappeared from his fundraising emails
after it was revealed by the intercept
that he along with some other twenty
twenty presidential candidates are
actually taking money from lobbyists or
have taken money from lobbyists so I'll
put up on the screen for people that are
watching along with me for a long time
Beto was sending out fundraising emails
like these where you see him say no
money from lobbyists or for example like
this one where you see him also say no
money from lobbyists and then the
intercepted a piece which exposed that
Beto O'Rourke as well as Kamala Harris
and Cory Booker actually are taking were
have been taking lobbyist donations and
then suddenly the fundraising emails by
Beto or works campaign that were sent
out after this intercept article was
published no longer mention anything
about no lobbyist the new one says we're
not taking money from PACs were not
taking money from corporations we're not
taking money from special interests
although special interest is a very sort
of vague word to be using but the
mention of lobbyists is gone so okay I
get that
this is being pushed a lot by anti Beto
people there are pro Burney groups that
are pushing this and making a big deal
out of it and this stuff
can very quickly get very very ugly and
there's also sort of a proud
maduk reality which is sometimes you say
no packs but if you win a primary all of
a sudden you lose control over those
whether there's pac money coming in to
support you the use of the term special
interests is a vague one what do we
really mean by special interests my view
of this and my goal in doing this story
today is not about playing gotcha with
Beto O'Rourke or with any particular
candidate because that's really not
going to help us win in 2020 which is
what I think the number one an almost
singular focus needs to be at this point
in time in addition to interfering with
as much of the destructive Republican
agenda as we can up until the point at
which we replace the people currently in
power I have sort of a much more
fatalistic and pragmatic view of this
which is that we at some point are going
to need to win with the rules that are
in place at the time that we're trying
to win if we ultimately want to really
get the amount of power that's necessary
to change the rules so this is why when
no PAC money became more of a thing
particularly for congressional
candidates I pointed out this is great I
agree with getting PAC money out but the
people who are doing it are making a
calculation they believe they can win
without the benefit of that money
it's the ideology of not taking PAC
money but to some degree it's also a
pragmatic calculation which is oK you've
got to make that calculation there was a
discussion back in 2016 about if Bernie
Sanders were to have won the 2016
Democratic nomination he would
inevitably have received the benefit of
PAC money because the Democratic Party
establishment would have used PACs to
support Bernie if he had been the
nominee so ultimately his promise can
remain technically true he's not
accepting PAC money but he'd still
benefit from the PAC from the fact that
PAC money would have been out there and
helping him and it would have been
beyond his control and it would have
just been a pragmatic reality at the
time that gets us to now you could
imagine a candidate taking the totally
principled stance on campaign finance
imagine a candidate who says I think
that camp
should be funded by small dollar
donations so not only am I not taking
PAC money or taking lobbyist money
whatever I'm also not taking donations
over two hundred and fifty bucks at some
point the completely correct principled
position will lose you the election or
make it impossible for you to win
because in the end more than more than
in most cases in something like 85% of
races the candidate with more money ends
up winning so I'm against all of these
types of campaign funding I've been
against them for years but I don't
believe in unilateral disarmament beyond
what makes sense at the time
no PAC money great it's the correct
moral decision and in many cases you can
still win without taking PAC money no
lobbyists money great it's the right
decision but how exactly are we defining
lobbyists money it's a little bit more
amorphous and if you get rid of
everything that could be called
lobbyists money can you still win a
presidential election I don't know the
answer I'm just asking the question so I
want to restate again I want lobbyists
money out I want PAC money out I want it
all out should Beto say he's not taking
lobbyist money if he actually is taking
it no that's what's called lying and he
shouldn't do that but when our opponents
are taking all of this money at some
point you have to just consider that if
you reject all of it you will lose and
never be in a position where you can
actually change the system so that
everybody stops taking this type of
money make everybody disarmed once
you're in power rather than unilaterally
disarming if it's going to make you lose
if you disagree with my take on this
sometimes people get angry at my
pragmatism just let me know I want to
hear from you one of today's David
Pakman show sponsors is east or built
who's giving everybody in our audience
20% off when you go to East or built
comm and use the promo code Pakman and
this part is awesome they're also giving
a portion of each purchase to Planned
Parenthood and the ACLU if you've been
thinking about starting your own online
store or upgrading the one you have
check out
store built it's a full-service set of
solutions they offer fully customized
websites for your webstore instructional
materials for improving your webstore
low-cost accounting services for your
webstore one web store created by e
store built was just recognized by
beheading dot-com as one of the top 25
best web stores of 2019 East store built
has team members specializing in
everything from Shopify to social media
marketing they can help your business
establish as an LLC which is a great way
to help protect your business from fraud
and lawsuits their team of certified
public accountants can take care of all
your bookkeeping your payroll your
electronic timekeeping and provide other
accounting consulting their accounting
team is headed up by a certified
management accountant with experience
managing business budgets of over 75
million dollars just go to East store
built calm I've put a link under this
video use promo code Pakman at check out
PA k man2 get 20% off your entire order
of e store startup products and
materials and if you're interested in
their affordable professional accounting
services just get in touch with them
using their website contact form tell
them David Pakman sent you and you'll
get 50% off your first month of
accounting services when you sign up for
a year subscription and don't forget
that they'll give a portion of all
purchases to Planned Parenthood and the
ACLU